good morning John it's been a almost two
years since our last big election here
in the US in Montana during that
election a weird thing happened while
Donald Trump was winning seventy percent
of the vote yet a governor who got
reelected with 54% of the vote who was a
Democrat and that just seems a little
bit like something that I don't
understand and that I would like
explained to me I have got coming into
my office today an expert on this topic
I think probably one of the preeminent
experts on this topic where do you look
right here or here yeah I mean you
people won't be able to tell difference
is the governor's Steve Bullock at the
governor of my state hello how do you
like my office if all of America in the
world could see it all
they can't you can only see this right
here I recently made some headlines when
the FCC was booing on ality gotta get
him to jail and this is a big deal in my
line of work and Montana I was sort of
surprised was the first state to come up
and say well no let's have it you signed
an executive order saying let's have
some protections at least here in the
state of Montana to maintain that
neutrality why and how does that work
what we did is said if you're going to
sell Internet services to the state of
Montana right you not only have to have
a free and open Internet from Montana
but for all Montana's you're not saying
that they can't do it they they can
block and throttle all they want but
that just means they can't sell services
to the state of Montana right or now the
state of New York New Jersey Hawaii yeah
Vermont as other governors have done the
same thing they base that legislation
off of what you wrote they basically
took our same executive order and we
even provided for a me governor you know
you can just click and fill in the
template do you see how this came about
though was pretty interesting my well my
staff came out said your daughter is
calling through your main switchboard
and I'm like why would Caroline call and
my main switchboard tried to God and she
had called our congressional
representatives voicing her concern and
some of her friends about repealing net
neutrality and my first answer was I'm
sorry honey I cannot do anything this is
a federal issue
but that got me thinking now yeah
actually the states could take the lead
on this when the administration is
trying to roll it back
you can thank Caroline for saving the
Internet thanks Caroline I've written in
my notes here Montana red state you
governor how that's what my notes say so
you know what I mean like I'm
legitimately very curious about this
from several angles like one I believe
in pushing good progressive agendas and
having you in charge of the state of
Montana really helps with that and like
like functionally helps a lot of people
second I think that we have a problem
with division in this country and it's
getting much worse and I hope that you
can provide me with some help first of
all how I got there and how I govern
isn't all that different those are kind
of the same thing - yeah meaning that I
show up I listen I engage with people I
don't just try to find people that share
all of my same thoughts but well you
don't have that luxury you can't go and
do that by damn again what do you want
you want a safe community you want clean
air and clean water good job roof over
your head so those are actually the
values that most people have that's what
we ought to be talking about from a
public policy standpoint we actually
have to talk to people yeah showing up
matters a lot would it be better for all
of us if we were trying to win every one
instead of just trying to mobilize the
base yes yes well you're never gonna win
every well of course you're never going
to but like but try but but like make
your case instead of just abandoning
whole sections of the electorate say
like I am out here for you and
nationally I think that's what exactly
what we need to do we need to listen and
we need to persuade the idea of winning
isn't about micro-targeting finding this
group or this person that fundamentally
agrees with everything and dragged them
to the polls yeah the idea is actually
to engage in that public sphere and say
here's why I will be fighting for you
20% of people who voted for you also
voted for Donald Trump that's right is
that seem impossible to you not at all
not at all
but because I think in this highly
polarized system you had too many people
say what's wrong with those voters as
opposed to what's wrong with us or can
if we're not actually speaking to those
voters and I know that that 20% that
also voted for Donald Trump they may not
agree with me on everything well my wife
are my children don't agree with me on
everything but I think they
fundamentally believe that I would be
fighting for them I'd be listening to
them I worry a lot about the erosion of
faith in press and in government and I
think a lot of people that run for
office are running against government
same government is a horrible look if
there are inefficiency sure there are
ways to make it better
but you ought to be running to be part
of the solution and I don't disagree I
mean the deal would delete
legitimization if that's even a word if
it's not inaudible I think the
legitimization is a word but I think the
thing you said it's not the tearing down
of the media a hashtag fake news for
anything that he might disagree with
that's that's not the way we run
represent our democracy so you've run
for office a couple of times a few times
I have it looks from the outside
terrible traveling all the time you're
away from your family but I'll see we
can track through the mud everything is
public does it suck this has had the
time to launch and green for governor
based on the way that you praise that's
the best advice I ever got was actually
from a Republican he was guy named Tom
Ridge you said you run to win but you
win to run so you run for office to win
but you win to run government I know
that we have kids and publicly funded
preschools now because of our work or
health care notwithstanding the fact
that yeah these horrible ad your focus
on what you can do it makes some of the
challenging parts a little bit less
challenging it sounds like a kind of
unique job maybe you don't really know
how to do when you show up first it like
is there a training course or like a
like a private discord channel just for
governor's to talk about governor stuff
yeah this is just between you and I I
don't actually know a hundred percent
how to governor right now yeah you your
peer group is small when you first get
elected there's something called well I
call it baby governor school they send
you down and maybe
how to stand like a governor or talk
like a governor versus a National
Governors Association okay so I was a
National Governors Association I was
right and I'm about to become the head
the chairman of the National Governors
Association come to summer you're in
your second term yeah ready to six years
I'd like to be in charge of it also
learn some for my peers and then what
you tried to do is surround yourself
with really good people listen hopefully
as much as you talk you start out just
drinking from a firehose and it's not
without a challenge I'm very interested
in having more young people interested
in running for office and being part of
government yep what would you say to
people who might not have considered
that yeah or maybe you're thinking about
it and like advice I mean there is no
magic age to get involved first of all
hmm
like we have a state legislature in
Montana that hadn't graduated high
school when he got elected there are so
many things that you can do growing up
but I know that I can pack people's live
be willing to take that step you may
fail but I've learned more from my
setbacks probably than my success you
are a Democrat and a gun culture state
we need to have a gun discussion in this
country can you give some insight into
how to like bring people into that
conversation rather than to sort of the
institutions that are trying to control
people's perspectives you know I talked
earlier about sort of how we share
values there was this group you that did
this big research project just last year
and said that two-thirds of the gun
owners one of the main reasons why they
element is to keep themselves or their
family or their communities safe and
they don't trust the government's
ability to do what those folks that want
some restrictions they want to keep
themselves in their community their
family safe they don't trust the
government's ability to do it with all
these firearms out there so I think that
there's more commonality than we would
think that we're not gonna solve all gun
violence but a public health approach
right with cars is we put in seatbelts I
didn't quite get there we put in airbags
didn't quite get there but we continued
to approve like we know that if we did
universal background checks we know that
it could make a meaningful difference
there's red flag laws the idea that
remember a law enforcement sees somebody
at a point where they could be a danger
the ability to go petition accord to
take their gun for a period of time we
know that there are things that can be
done you know you'd asked earlier about
young people getting involved parkland
Florida students may actually
fundamentally change and when we saw in
Montana students walking out just in
recognition and protest so maybe this
will finally be the time where the
grown-ups are listening to the kids what
are you most afraid of like in terms of
not in terms of like your own personal
existential dread United States always
been the place that everyone looks to as
a beacon of hope the beacon of
opportunity in some respects we are
advocating our role as the international
leader and I can say that from
everything from climate to coalition's
where we're trying to do peacekeeping I
worry as you had mentioned too about the
divisive nacinda system and look
everybody's life isn't consumed with
what happens in government uh-huh but if
government isn't working it can
negatively impact everybody's life what
do you must worry about supposed to ask
questions this is a remarkable
opportunity to see my family and thank
you so much for coming by and on the
cheer I imagine super busy that's very
cool it was my pleasure from there's a
really appreciate it as well that's fun
yeah if you want to watch more of my
interview with governor Bullock where we
talk more about what it's like to be
governor voting and what we're afraid of
stuff like that I've taken some of the
bits that I took out of this and put it
up on Hanks channel this was a
fascinating and cool thing to be able to
do as the governor was leaving said it
thing that I've been thinking about ever
since he said that if you win by writing
off everybody who disagrees with you and
only pulling the people who really
deeply agree with you to the polls then
maybe win the election but also maybe
you lose the ability to govern we might
be seeing what that looks like right now
but if government stops working yes that
hurts everybody but it especially hurts
the people who need help the most
John educational videos are exempt from
time limits and I will see you
Tuesday I wish you safe daughter so I
and that's my $2.00 so did you already
snap me or should I say hi or something
oh yeah what do you say hello it
their names are Caroline and Alex hello
Caroline and Alex this is weird but we
passed one of the most progressive
campaign disclosure laws or are you
serious Travis did you start swearing a
lot if we want to come yeah well what
you want to be relatable to the youths
so if you could just like I don't know
sale it